reflect for a moment on just how alien
life on our own planet can be there are
countless species on earth that seem
commonplace to us but if you think from
the perspective of an interstellar
visitor seeing them for the first time
you'll realize that much of what nature
produces on a daily basis seems more
outlandish than the vast majority of
science fiction so if we were ever to
discover alien life it's highly likely
we'd find it mind-blowing and maybe even
a little disturbing one science fiction
project which truly excels at accurately
representing these likelihoods is snyad
which is one of the most detailed
speculative biology projects of all time
the famous fictional world of snyad is
the creation of the one and only cm
kozaman author of valtamaros and expert
in all things alien who you can follow
and support in the links below this
online worldbuilding project includes
more than 200 extraterrestrial life
forms from several dozen lineages in an
awe-inspiring amount of detail about
each one so for this entry into the
archive i'll be taking you on a
documentary-style tour across this truly
alien planet and exploring just some of
the life that dwells on its surface
at first glance the anatomy of most life
on snyad might confuse the common
observer to understand the life forms
that we'll encounter on our voyage let's
first take a kahidron a rather average
organism by sniaddy standards as an
example examining the inner workings of
the kahydron you'll find a host of
surprises beginning with the skeletal
system sniaddy bones aren't made from
calcium but a modified hydrocarbon
composite that resembles very hard wood
while extremely durable these bones burn
easily which complicates things for
sciatic paleontologists sniati mussels
are equally distinctive they work via
hydraulics moving by pushing instead of
pulling and their bones have evolved to
accommodate this difference strange
though these muscles may be they provide
their owners with incredible strength
relative to their size but the oddities
don't end there snyaty creatures also
possess a second set of traditional
fiber-based muscles which cover the
entire body and help pump the fluid of
their hydraulic counterparts the
respiratory and circulatory systems of
sniaddy animals are similarly unique
with the nostrils of most organisms
located near their armpits these
nostrils are connected to lungs that
work independently from one another in a
highly distinctive setup yet the most
divergent system in sniaddy animals is
their brains actually two organs that
work in tandem the first component of
the brain is a dense knot of fibrous
nerves connected to a larger system and
the second is a cryptic structure that
seems to be the root of consciousness in
each organism although the author
imagines that visiting or scientists
struggle to understand it but perhaps
the most noticeable deviation from
familiar life is that almost all
vertebrates on snyad appear to have two
heads in reality the first head contains
the organism's jaws eyes and
reproductive system but isn't actually
connected to the digestive tract at all
instead all food consumption is done via
the second head which is almost like an
exposed throat that leads to the stomach
this unconventional arrangement is a
holdover from a distant ancestor which
most vertebrates on snyad are descended
from in the kahydran's case the jaws of
the first head are built for hunting as
the life-form occupies an apex predator
role similar to an earthly lion just in
its own unmistakably alien fashion
indeed we'll find much of the life on
sniad bears some surface similarities to
earthly species although others truly
defy
classification a great place to continue
our tour is in the mountainous forests
here you can find the aeronics a
relative of the kahidron and member of
the larger kahydrana form classification
like hulka hydrana forms the aronix is
also a predator with a short crushing
bite and long scythe-like claws the
aeronics is more than just a true
carnivore however but also a part-time
omnivore like various species of earth
bears at 16 feet or 5 meters in length
though the powerful or runex rivals even
the largest bears in its sheer size
within the rivers of an equatorial
jungle you can find an aquatic hydrana
form called the crocohydran roughly the
same length as the aaronics the
crocohydron paddles on adapted fins
snapping up organisms with its elongated
jaws a striking mix of a leafy sea
dragon and an earth crocodile the
crocohydron is an effective predator
lying in weight before snapping up its
unsuspecting prey
but sniad is more than a world of
predators dotting the endless lush
plains the mainly herbivorous kettle
turts wander the grasslands plucking
nutritious plants from the soil with
their second head the kettle turts are
members of the turtiforms a wide-ranging
group that bears some resemblance to
turtles or tortoises on our own planet
unlike the earthly analogs however the
shells of turtiforms aren't external but
are instead encased in a layer of skin
turtle forms also aren't able to
withdraw their limbs into their shell
when threatened
but turtiforms don't just populate the
land in the water marine tertiforms like
the streamlined cylindroids genus have
become uniquely adapted to their aquatic
environment their shell has become a
heavy hydrodynamic hull and the digits
on their limbs have become broad paddles
which they use to steer themselves
through the vast oceans much like sea
turtles on earth most species of sea
turtles lay their eggs on land forcing
their young to make a perilous journey
back to the ocean cleverly however
cylindroids have evolved to birth their
young without ever leaving the water
in the forested mountain ranges
bordering the great northern ocean a
one-of-a-kind hunter is looking for food
this is a toxic losses a member of the
diverse polydactyl classification and a
relative of the turtiforms these tiny
life-forms possess a spring-like
extendable second head which they use to
zap their unsuspecting prey this hunting
strategy shows a remarkable degree of
convergent evolution with chameleons of
earth who use their long strange tongues
to consume insects after all life on our
own planet can be downright alien as
well
and flattened along the bottom of
freshwater rivers you might also find
the peaceful platy malloc a polydactyl
offshoot that had become bottom-feeding
life-forms that spend most of their time
underwater not an active bunch to feed
the platymolek drag their vacuum-like
second heads over the muck to scoop up
any potential food sort of like the
feeding habits of some species of
stingray which also have unusual mouths
on the underside of their bodies unlike
stingrays however platymoleks aren't
particularly elegant nor do they have
much of a defense against potential
predators burrowing just under the soil
the blind unassuming vermin phagus make
their tunnels content to be ignored by
the more fantastical sniaty organisms
that stomp above ground vermin phagus
are our first example of a haplobracket
a group that is united by their lack of
limbs yet nonetheless have become
remarkably successful most haplobrackets
burrow in layers of spongy vegetation
called sprog which covers large swaths
of snyad's surface one carnivorous
haplobracket that tunnels within the
sprog are the cytogenathis meter-sized
life-forms that have evolved a
distinctive hunting strategy their
second heads have become specialized
lures that mimic the appearance of
common prey animals like the anglerfish
or frogfish of earth the cytogenathus
simply sticks the lure out and wiggles
it around in a bizarre manner that
resembles the movement of their prey
luring curious life forms right into the
predator's jaws
impressively some haplo brackets have
even taken to the trees among the
branches the large sloth snakes slowly
slither towards their next meal of fruit
or vegetation at a surprising 13 feet or
4 meters long sloth snakes are easily
the largest of the haplobrackets as you
can imagine their nickname comes from
their surface level similarities to both
slow-moving sloths and limbless arboreal
snakes although like many creatures on
snyad the sloth snakes don't neatly fit
into any earthly category
on the subject of earthly or non-earthly
counterparts there are no traditional
insects on planet sniad instead that
role is filled by curious life forms
like the four millimeter long dactylopis
these evolutionary oddities are a type
of picozoen organisms that were once
large terrestrial vertebrates but became
tiny life forms over millions of years
since organisms the size of insects
require a variety of adaptations to
function this grand shift in size
involved various unusual shortcuts like
bones that never ossified during
development and a worm-like larval stage
that allows pycozoans to inhabit
different niches as adults and juveniles
look closely at the leaves in the
jungles of the east and you might spot
the rare arbovermis a slightly larger
and more distinctive picozoen also
called grinchworms these endangered
green lifeforms shuffled their long
tube-like bodies around on numerous tiny
legs as a result their walking gait is
likely not unlike the movements of
caterpillars or centipedes although
grinchworms don't have quite as many
legs to get around with
strange as picozoens are however on the
isolated island continent of thelassa
groups have evolved that resemble no
other life forms on snyad for an example
look no further than the carnivorous
oficotonos a type of monoantic etherean
that lacks front limbs altogether a
challenging species to decode the
ophikotonos possess long spear-like
lower jaws on their first heads that
help them jab their preferred prey which
dwells below ground in fishing for
organisms with their long beaks their
hunting behavior is somewhat similar to
that of certain birds
on the vast plains of the lassa island
you can spot the herbivorous bounder
jaws a species of monoantic ethereans
that patrol the plains and vast herds
these creatures might look a little off
balance but they actually have a highly
efficient method of specialized
locomotion their legs contain
piston-like hydraulic muscles that allow
them to leap about storing energy from
one bound to another a bit like a
kangaroo although clearly only in
certain regards
on a nearby island an equally atypical
life form patrols the scrub land the red
headbanger is a solitary predator with a
strange name and even stranger hunting
method charging out of nowhere the
headbanger dispatches unwary prey with
hatchet-like blows of its massive head
while an impressive organism the
headbanger's island isolation is key to
its survival as on a nearby landmass
truly terrifying goliaths are waiting
meet the size mopis weighing over a ton
these giants are easily one of the
biggest predators on all of snyhad a
type of tromo bracket seismopus have
fused their secondary heads with their
sternums and front limbs and have
evolved the strongest jaw equivalents in
all of snyad this gives them the
advantage of being able to chew and
swallow from the same mouth with their
first heads becoming thin periscope-like
organisms only useful for observation
not surprisingly the tromo brackets have
become quite successful upon the vast
sands of the interior desert the related
amodromius or sand runner pursues prey
to the point of exhaustion like the
hyenas of earth these ruthless hunters
often cooperate in a pack to take down
larger prey although this behavior is
likely the simple result of intersecting
interests rather than genuine
cooperative behavior
but even a pack of sand runners might be
wary of titaniforms like z ero forests
or giant skip birds some of the
mightiest herbivores on snyad at almost
20 feet or 6 meters in length giant
skippers are well protected while they
grind down vegetation with their
oversized plant-munching second heads
indeed their feeding habits are somewhat
like an elephant although giant skip
birds grow to even greater sizes but
surprisingly they're not the largest of
the titanoforms
at last we've reached the final life
form we'll be archiving in this video at
almost 40 feet or 12 meters long
legendary magna dyers are one of the
largest land animals on snyad
often simply called titans the second
head of these herbivores have become
super extended into long almost
drawbridge like structures these
gigantic animals spend their days
grazing in a large circle twice as wide
as their second head necks
we've barely covered half the orders in
the snyad project and there's many more
individual species from each order you
can read about online in part two we'll
investigate even larger and stranger
life forms but for now our time in this
incredible alien world has come to an
end if you want to support the author
you can follow and support seam kozuman
using the links below he's also working
on a book that will overhaul many of the
species with updated details which i'm
really excited for also thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this entry
please lend your support and like
subscribe and hit the notification icon
to stay up to date on all things curious
see you in the next video
you